[Music]
a new contract approved the news just
came down this morning that Dr Jesus
Jara will remain the CCSD superintendent
for four more years after trustees voted
4-3 to renew Sasha Loftus joins us live
at CCSD headquarters and Sasha with that
extension there is a big pay increase
yes Christian it comes with a whopping
76 thousand dollar raise which would
bring Dr Jesus jara's contract his
annual salary to 395 thousand dollars
now this was a sickening point for some
of the trustees who did vote against
this decision today a large part of this
agreement which passed as you said with
a 4-3 vote also says in the event that
Dr Dora was fired his contract would be
bought out the tune of about two million
dollars this comes nearly a week after
the board raided Dr Jara as highly
effective in his job evaluation but
you'll remember back in October trustees
voted to remove the superintendent from
his position then backpeddled and
reinstated him while Dr Dara accepted
the terms trustee Daniel Ford did not
one of three voting against it
I am extremely grateful for the
opportunity that has been granted by the
majority of the sport
to continue continue to lead this great
District I am a
vehemently against this contract the way
it was done and
the expense that is going to cost the
taxpayer and the absolute
disrespect to the constituents
now this agreement will take effect in
January when Dr jarro's current contract
expires Dr Jara would be required to
give a 90-day notice if he resigns and
this contract is set to run through
2026. reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now